all right well let's uh let's rag on
gently a little bit yeah so we have this
story from the independent saki says is
is her name saki is it sake bomb
says peter ducey sounds like a stupid
son of uh
yeah or she keep it family friendly
because of fox's questions biden caught
on hot mike in january calling ducey a
stupid sob over inflation question and
then
saki just comes out and says it i just
want to point out um
i was watching peter ducey question jen
at the white house press briefing today
and i was offended at how bad she was at
this because i've praised her in the
past as being a good spin doctor because
you know biden will do something just
horrifyingly bad or he'll just like fall
asleep in public or something i'm
kidding by the way but he'll he'll
and she'll find a way to spin it and i'm
like yeah she's good i mean she's doing
what she does but today it was just like
wow and you know well let me explain
yeah she was asking peter ducey why
do you recommend masks when we don't
have to and her response was i'm not a
doctor are you a doctor you're not a
doctor i'm not a doctor and i'm like jen
like wow this one's really easy you just
say airplanes are smaller with
recirculated air yeah i was like you
couldn't even just say that to peter
ducey he's like wow
she was not good at this there were a
couple other things that came out and
she was bad
but
the interesting thing here i suppose is
that she's she's reportedly going to
msnbc so here she is it's it's during a
taping of pod save america oh yeah she
was asked if mr ducey was a stupid sob
or if he just acted like one on tv
she said he works for a network that
provides people with questions that
nothing personal to any individual
including ducey but might make anyone
sound like a stupid sob that's really
amazing that the only real questions
that come out of that briefing okay it's
not fair but 90 of the real questions
come from peter ducey
there there were um
there was one guy i saw asking some good
questions but i'm sitting there watching
this briefing and i'm just like has
there ever been a point in our lifetimes
where the white house press briefing
revealed any
relevant or important information or are
we all just recognizing it's it's it's
it's theater and and the the whether it
be sean spicer or jensecki they're gonna
say whatever they have to to spin
they're not going to tell you the truth
for once i'd like someone to come out
with like a scotch and it's like you
know just donald trump or biden and he's
like swirling it and they're like what
are we doing in yemen
making a lot of money
we're selling weapons to the saudis you
know they're and they're blowing up
villages but good for the economy next
question syria ooh oil well we're trying
to build a pipeline what's next and i'm
just like wow you know but they're not
going to do that i would love to see
inside of kaley mack and mcinerney's big
book that she used to carry with her i
would love to see what's in there okay i
gotta take that back yes she's great
that was epic she had the big book and
whenever the press would say something
she's like hmm and she's like reference
you're full of it okay that was actually
substantive yeah that maybe wasn't
giving us real answers about the
administration but it was exposing to
the american people how the media was
totally full of it yeah when this girl
when we talk about how she uh is good i
think that's come up in the past that
she's good at her job i'm like well you
can be good at your job and be evil if
your job is evil like joseph goebbels
hitler's minister of propaganda was good
but so instead of using the word good
say effective say he did it don't say he
was good say he was he was effective at
his job which was evil and so is jen
sackey sometimes if she's lying to
people that's evil you could say she's
doing a public good by lying to people
because some of the the information is
too dangerous like the cia is a
secretive organization on purpose but i
don't think that's i don't know what do
you think about it if there is any man
on the planet
who is the easiest to take out of
context and make a
montage of just four or five things yes
thank you tim you recognize my greatness
you need your own gensake thank
you
no no but the the issue is
you know ian made a good point just now
that uh goebbels yeah joseph joseph
goebbels or something he was effective
and it was terrifying but when you say
that
when
he was good at his job and he was evil
when he said he was good yeah but i kind
of got stopped diverted i'm like you got
to make sure you finish that
he was effective so were the nazis and
what they were trying to accomplish but
they weren't good and so that's so you
can look at what jen's doing i mean
she's now she's just bad at her job and
also doing i don't know if i want to
claim she's doing evil but
i want to i want to have hope for the
american government but sometimes i
think like a little transparency goes a
long way you know they're checked out i
think they're all evil i mean they've
been forcing mass on little kids in
airplanes you know kicking families off
because a two-year-old won't wear their
mask you know uh
child suicide rates are through the roof
right now drug addictions up through the
roof everyone who pushes this is evil
i'm totally fine with using that word uh
they're good at being evil i guess
they're effective at being equal i agree
and i want to elaborate on that when you
have a machine that says two-year-olds
must wear masks yeah and we're like okay
we get it but then you get these videos
like even people willing to be like we
want to do we we want to be peaceful we
don't want confrontation you get these
videos
where the baby they put the mask on the
baby and the baby takes it off
like literal baby and then they're like
off the plane
and i'm like dude when you have become
this machine that doesn't care about
people you have become evil and i've
talked about it before i can't stand
what has become of the us court system
it's been this way
to varying degrees but it's getting
worse in that
i i get pulled over once i wasn't
speeding
cop walks up to me with a ticket and he
says sign there and i was like i wasn't
speeding because i don't care talk to a
judge and i was like no now i gotta take
off work to go to a judge i go to the
judge and goes i don't care cop said you
were speeding pay the fine or
you know fight it and i'm like
okay
you know we've become extremely rigid
because we don't know or care about each
other and this is one of the big
challenges the way we use you know this
country is founded we had two million
people you didn't have police you had
local militia so if somebody stole
something it's like round up the boys
we're gonna go we're gonna go catch that
guy who stole something and then you'd
have to go to the courts and the courts
were part of the community everybody
knew each other and they'd all
talk it out and it's like that guy who
stole it that's that's that's you know
john's son and it's like oh man john
what do you got to say for your kid and
then they talk about it now it's like i
don't know what this guy is i don't even
know his name is now there's so many
people and it's so dense we've just
become rigid and mechanized almost i see
ups and downs to both because if you
know the judge and then you commit a
crime and the judge is like i know i'm
just let them off that's also bad but if
you the judge has no idea who you are
and they don't take your humanity into
account at all then that's also kind of
bad i i agree but i i think of it like
this still exists in small town america
where uh if you live in a small town
and you're speeding let's say a 16 seven
year old kid is speeding and the the
deputy pulls him over he already knows
who it is so he's not worried about
getting shot or anything and he walks up
and he's like jimmy why speeding and
he's like i'm sorry dan and he's like
i'm going to see your dad at the bar
later today and i'm going to tell him
your speed and he's like please don't
and he's like i'm let you off with a
warning but i'm telling you're dead like
that's way more effective social
repercussions as opposed to like pay the
35 bucks or pay the 50 bucks for a lot
of people at 50 bucks is devastating but
they're like i don't care you know so
what i'll i'll not pay the ticket or
i'll fight it or whatever having that
personal connection i think is good
because it holds people to account
because they're scared of people they
know and love getting mad at them i
think you're right about that and
there's also just that there's two darn
many laws
so we've got so many people going
through the system all the time it
almost has to be
uh mechanical and expedited you really
can't add the human element in if you've
got it's let's say you're a judge and
you've got a judge on
50 cases in a day or whatever how
serious can you take the individual on
each of those i mean there's only so
many minutes in a day yeah they're
they're gonna
especially not even just judges but
prosecutors they're only going to see
you as a number or as a way to advance
their career and it's almost not even
like
i'd like to say it's on them but a
career-oriented person who goes into a
field like that they're going to be
predisposed to looking at people that
way and that's just how they uh they've
chosen to get ahead with their career
they just happen to take a career that
puts other people's lives in you know in
the balance each and every day yeah then
you have to ask yourself why they chose
that job that's a whole other discussion
they're they're i pulled up just like
weird laws but one of them is like bingo
games can't last more than five hours in
north carolina you can't sniff glue with
the intent to get high from it in
indiana
can't have sex with living fish in
minnesota okay i might actually support
that one yeah that that's not a weird
law that's a good one that's the word
living
there's like a song where they
referenced that and i was like that
can't be real can it and then i don't
know if that's they've since uh repealed
that just to say any fish perhaps but
yes that was that was a thing this is a
great metaphor talking about the machine
we were talking last night about how
machines are very dangerous and we've
kind of become enslaved to them they're
very intelligent and we can build their
intelligence but they have no emotion
humans have emotion that's why we
enslave the machine to work for us and
to outsource our intelligence at what
level does a society become a machine
like a small town it's all about emotion
who you know your kids their kids then
all of a sudden at some point it's like
just fill out the paperwork you don't
even have to look at the guy's face like
what sixty thousand people
twenty hundred and six sixteen hundred
people
remember that movie office uh what was
it office space when they take the
printer out and beat the tar out of it
or whatever you are the printer
oh that's the tech that's the
technocratic dream yeah i mean well i
mean i just think that uh
fundamentally that movie is about being
caught up in a
mindless numbing job that's functioning
a lot like a bureaucracy and every level
of justice system is a mindless numbing
bureaucracy so when you go in there
you're the printer man and printers are
still worthy of that like we have a
printer here that they're all awful it's
the only technology that hasn't expanded
at all every printer is still a hassle
to use all the time did you guys ever
have that black printer ink explode on
you when you're trying to change it it's
so crazy it's like there's like a rule
against making them better they're like
it has to be a hassle and it's just
nobody wants to nobody wants to create a
better printer i agree yeah maybe lasers
maybe we can just have lasers do a back
image on a paper it's probably created
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you